let's see we've got a lot of people
holding why don't we go next to our
caller from the 954 area code caller
from 954 who's this where are you
calling from hi this is AK I'm calling
from Naples Florida oh hey what's going
on okay let me ask you something what's
the temperature in Naples right now
because I might be down in that part of
the that neck of the woods in in
February and I'm wondering how warm it's
going to be
oh it's been about 75 80 that's pretty
good good what's Wednesday average I
know oh I don't know I've been stuck
inside all the time so I wouldn't be
able to tell you all right well maybe
after you can get a thermometer in the
water there and report back to me okay
sure okay what's going on so after
seeing I you know watch the address last
night by Trump and over the whole
presidency I've kind of realized that a
lot of assumptions are made that the
president is going to do things in good
faith and use restrain or common sense
and I'm wondering after this whole
debacle especially with him teasing the
idea of declaring a national emergency
would it be possible to put some more
rules in place in the future so that
things that are it's such a moral gray
area to say what is right and wrong but
some of the stuff just objectively is I
mean it's just crazy give their weight
what kind of rules are you thinking of
maybe more a more specific description
of the power of that declaring a
national emergency or I don't know a
literacy test for the president literacy
test is an interesting one particularly
because of the dark history of literacy
tests in the United States right like
it's funny that you're thinking about it
because we've got a [ __ ] for president
but in the in the in most American
history the idea of
literacy test was actually floated to
disenfranchise the disproportionately
poor and minorities so I mean I I
completely am on board with you that I
questioned Trump's intellectual
abilities and cognitive abilities I
don't think a literacy test is gonna fly
though yeah because I wasn't I thought I
was thinking you know literacy test for
something but then that flashed in my
mind that it disenfranchises people but
or maybe even something along the lines
of the way that his administration was
acknowledging the press right you know
no politician tells the truth but the
amount of misinformation and purposeful
misleading of the public is that can
that be quantified can that here's the
thing we had a voicemail on the
Wednesday show that said also what about
like what about a constitutional
amendment to require some previous
elected office to be eligible for
president and with all of this stuff
what you're bringing up with that caller
brought up on Wednesday's show my
instinct is not that we need more
restrictions on who can be President or
on presidential power we need to realize
that we have to be more responsible when
it comes to who we vote in and that
includes if you didn't vote you should
vote because only half the country votes
and merely by increasing voter turnout
we would have been able to prevent the
atrocity that is the donald trump
presidency so my instinct is not to try
to make more laws or put in more
regulations about the presidency it's to
fight for a more informed electorate
that would never elect such a buffoon in
the first place that's how I would focus
my energy on the problem yeah probably
more restrictions as a kind of a later
ditch effort when we can try to improve
ourselves again yeah and it is very hard
because any restriction that you think
would only hurt the other side or be a
completely reasonable minimum
restriction things can change and it can
end up kind of backfiring and not really
working well so I would hesitate to do
anything like that but glad you're
thinking about the stuff Zach thank you
for the call
thank you all right
I hope to hear from you again